I was visiting MIT looking for a place
to get a PhD and I wanted to do some
laboratory work and one of my professors
at in the Aero Department said go see
this guy mark raber down in the basement
of the AI lab
and so I walked down there and saw him
he showed me his robots
and he showed me this robot doing a
somersault
and I just immediately went whoa you
know yeah robots can do that and because
of my own interest in in gymnastics
there was like this immediate connection
and you know I was interested in I was
in an arrow Astro degree because you
know flight and movement was all so
fascinating to me and then it turned out
that you know robotics had this big
challenge how do you how do you balance
uh how do you how do you build a Lego
robot that can really get around
and that just that was a Fascination and
it still exists today you're still
working on perfecting Motion in robots
what about the elegance and the beauty
of the movement itself is is there
something
maybe grounded in your appreciation of
uh movement from your gymnastics days
did you
was there something you just
fundamentally appreciate about the
elegance and beauty of movement you know
we had this concept in in gymnastics of
um letting your body do what it wanted
to do when you get really good at
gymnastics
um part of what you're doing is putting
your your body into a position where the
physics and the body's inertia and
momentum will kind of push you in the
right direction in a very natural and
organic way
and the thing that Mark was doing you
know in the basement of that laboratory
was trying to figure out how to build
machines to take advantage of those
ideas how do you build something so that
the physics of the machine just kind of
inherently wants to do what it wants to
do and he was building these springy
pogo stick type you know his first cut
at lugged Locomotion was a pogo stick
where it's bouncing and there's a spring
Mass
a system that's oscillating has its own
sort of natural frequency there and sort
of figuring out how to augment those
natural physics
with also intent how do you then control
that but not overpower it
it's that coordination that I think
creates real potential we could call it
Beauty you know you could call it I
don't know Synergy uh that people have
different words for it but I think that
that was inherent uh from the beginning
that was clear to me that that's part of
what Mark was trying to do he asked me
to do that in my research work so
um you know that's where I got going so
part of the thing that I think I'm
calling elegance and Beauty in this case
which was there even with the Pogo
stickers maybe the the efficiency so
letting the body do what it wants to do
trying to discover the efficient
movement it's definitely more efficient
it also
um becomes easier to control in its own
way because the physics are solving some
of the problem itself it's not like you
have to do all this calculation and
overpower the physics the physics
naturally inherently want to do the
right thing
there can even be you know a feedback
mechanisms stabilizing mechanisms
that occur simply by virtue of the
physics of the body and it's you know
not all
not all on the computer or not even all
in your mind as a person and I there's
something interesting in that melding
you were with Mark for many many many
years but you were there in this kind of
legendary space
of leg lab and on my team in the
basement all great things happen in the
basement is there some memories uh is
there some memories from that time
that you have because it's so it's such
Cutting Edge work
in in in robotics and artificial
intelligence
the memories the distinctive lessons I
would say I learned in that in that time
period
and um and that I think Mark was a great
teacher of
was uh it's okay to pursue your
interests your curiosity do something
because you love it
um you'll do it a lot better if you love
it
um
that that is a lasting lesson that I
think uh we apply at the company still
um and really is a core value so the
interesting thing is I got to um
uh with people like Russ Cedric and um
and others like the students that work
at those robotics labs are like some of
the happiest people I've ever met
I don't know what that is I mean a lot
of PhD students a lot of them are kind
of broken by the wear and tear of the
process uh but roboticists are while
they work extremely hard and work long
hours
there's a
uh there's a happiness there the only
other group of people I've met like that
are people that Skydive a lot like for
for some reason there's a deep
fulfilling happiness maybe from like a
long period of struggle to get a thing
to work and it works and there's a magic
to it I don't know exactly because it's
so fundamentally Hands-On and you're
bringing a thing to life I don't know
what it is but they're happy
we see you know our our attrition at the
company is really low people come and
they love the pursuit
and I think part of that is that there's
perhaps an extra connection to it it's a
little bit easier to connect when you
have a robot that's moving around in the
world and part of your goal is to make
it move around in the world you can
identify with that and and this is on a
this is one of the unique things about
the kinds of robots we're building is
this physical interaction
lets you perhaps identify with it so I
think that is a source of happiness I
don't think it's Unique to robotics I
think anybody also who is just pursuing
something they love
it's easier to work hard at it and be
good at it and
um
not everybody gets to find that I I do
feel lucky in that way and I think we're
lucky as an organization that we've been
able to build a business around this and
that keeps people engaged
so if it's all right let's link on mark
for a little bit longer Mark raybert so
he he's a legend
uh he's a legendary engineer and robota
says what what have you learned about
life about robotics remark through all
the many years you've worked with him
I think the most important lesson which
was you know have the courage of your
convictions and and do what you think is
interesting
um be willing to try to find big big
problems to go after and at the time you
know like it Locomotion
um especially in a dynamic machine
nobody had solved it and that felt like
a multi-decade problem to go after
and so you know have the courage to go
after that because you're interested
don't worry if it's gonna make money you
know that that's been a theme so that
that's really uh probably the most uh
important lesson I think that uh I got
from Mark how crazy is the effort of
doing legged
robotics at that time especially
you know Mark got some stuff to work uh
starting from the simple ideas so maybe
the other another important idea that
has really become a value of the company
is try to simplify a thing to the Core
Essence
and and while you know Mark was showing
videos of animals running across the
Savannah or uh uh climbing mountains
what he started with was a pogo stick
because he was trying to reduce the
problem to something that was manageable
and and getting the pogo stick to
balance had in it
the fundamental problems that if we
solve those you could eventually
extrapolate to something that galloped
like a horse